[Musique]
la magie tournoi sans relâche autour de
nous elle est dans l'air que nous
respirons
mais attention n'ayez pas la naïveté de
croire que nous sommes les seuls à
pouvoir maîtriser sa puissance
[Musique]
félicitations pour votre admission à
l'université de belgrade
tiens tiens déjà une question qu'est ce
que tu sais au sujet de l'ordre de la
rose peuple c'est bidon cette histoire
de sociétés secrètes
[Musique]
vous êtes sur le point de vivre une des
plus grandes aventures de votre vie
[Musique]
il semblerait que vous ayez été choisi
acceptez-vous votre devoir
oui
nous espérons que vous accomplirez de
grandes choses
bienvenue dans l'ordre mon devoir est de
t'apprendre à utiliser la magie mon
mentor le hasard a voulu qu'on se
retrouve ensemble on va dire que j'ai eu
la chance il ya une créature qui rôde la
2 to le dessin est décimé toute nouvelle
recrue
quant à sion la plus puissante qui ait
jamais été inventé
peut faire tout devient possible
si tu ne fais rien il va y avoir encore
plus de morts
nous allons bâtir un monde
extraordinaire
c'est ce pourquoi tu as signé dès le
départ à 16
la magie a toujours un coût et si tu
payes pas le prix ça peut mal se passer
[Musique]